all the eyes in the space enthusiast
community are fixed at tesla's starship
facility at boca chica texas this is all
in anticipation of the first ever flight
test of spacex's booster stage for the
starship aptly named the super heavy and
from all the details we know about super
heavy we can say for sure that there
will be a lot of super heavy carrying
being done by this massive 230 foot tall
powerhouse so let us briefly dive into
why super heavy is a game changer in the
space industry and what are the things
that make it so great to understand the
significance of the super heavy and elon
musk's plan to eventually colonize mars
with a massive fleet of starships we
first need to take a brief tour of the
development history of the super heavy
project but to keep it brief we will
just skim through the overall evolution
of spacex's starship project because yes
super heavy has been part of the
starship program from the start as a
booster stage for any future rocket that
would be used for interplanetary travel
we know that spacex was developing a
launch vehicle to go to mars as far back
as 2012. spacex ceo and potential mars
colonizer elon musk mentioned that
spacex was already working on a launch
vehicle that would be developed into a
fleet of spaceships that would take
humanity to mars it was called the mars
colonial transport back then or mct for
short and the past nine years haven't
diverted from the core design choices
made back then for such a transport
spaceship spacex wanted to create
reusable rockets this would be done in
two stages the first stage would be a
massive booster rocket that would do
most of the grunt work for helping the
second stage i.e the rocket carrying the
passengers and cargo into orbit this
second stage once in orbit or near orbit
would separate from the booster stage
and continue the journey on its own
power this was not something new nasa
and other national space agencies had
been doing that for decades booster
stages were a pretty common concept in
space flight to cut down the weight a
rocket ship had to carry especially
because it would become dead weight once
all the fuel and oxidizer was used up
spacex wanted to go a step further
usually booster rockets would just drop
into the ocean or desert sometimes they
can be refurbished and used again but
other times these booster stage rockets
would just be a useless hunk of metal
for scrap elon thought why not make
these rockets reusable and develop
technologies to land the boosters in one
piece it also went really well with
spacex's whole vision of using reusable
rockets and spacex would go ahead to
have very significant success with their
reusable rocket the falcon 9. this
program went through multiple designs
and even name changes as the starship
project evolved into what it is today
after the development of the mars
colonial transport for a few years
nearing the end of september 2016 elon
musk pointed out that since the
transporter would be able to go beyond
mars a name change was needed the name
selected at the time was interplanetary
transport system or its for short but
this would be short-lived as one year
later elon musk while talking at the
68th annual meeting of the international
astronautical congress said that they
were still searching for the right name
but internally it was being called the
bfr the more formal meaning of this
acronym was big falcon rocket but
informally inside the company and on the
internet it was known by a less clean
name meanwhile its booster stage would
just be known as the booster stage or
the first stage of the rocket throughout
it wasn't until 2019 when the project
settled for its final name starship that
the booster stage got its own unique
identity as the super heavy side by side
with the development of the starship
program for years spacex was also
developing their own engine that would
be used to power both the starship the
upper stage and super heavy the booster
stage this engine which we now know as
the raptor engine was specifically being
designed for these two rockets while a
detailed discussion on the raptor engine
merits its own video in short the raptor
engine was made with four things in mind
one it should be very cheap to produce
two it should be very easy to mass
produce it meaning the design should be
as simple as possible three it should be
very easy to source the fuel for it on
mars four it should be made with
reusability in mind and up until now it
seems that spacex will be able to live
to these goals and these are the bad
boys that will power the super heavy
into orbit exactly 33 of them the number
keeps changing initially it was
announced that 37 raptor engines would
power the super heavy then it came down
to 31 engines in 2020. then elon later
tweeted the number would be 28. since
then we are sitting on 33 being the
number of raptor engines that will power
the rocket so where do we currently
stand with the super heavy the super
heavy stands at 70 meters in height and
9 meters in diameter super heavies are
designated by the term bn and then a
number bn1 and bn2 prototypes didn't
make it to testing the first time we saw
the super heavy in its full glory was
the bn3 or booster 3 as the press likes
to call it after being developed for two
months super heavy bm3 was taxi to a
launch pad and assemble but it was later
revealed that bn3 would just be
restricted to ground tests the final
variant of the super heavy is planned to
be powered using 33 raptor engines
according to elon musk this will be in a
2010 three configuration meaning 20
raptor engines in the outside ring then
10 in the inner ring and finally three
more inside all 33 raptor engines
combined would give the super heavy a
thrust of 27 mega newtons to put this
into comparison nasa's saturn v rocket
the largest rocket that nasa ever
operated only produced a thrust of 35
mega newtons so this is not something to
joke about the plan with a super heavy
is that once it helps the second stage
reach orbit it will perform a deorbit
burn and then fall back to earth but
instead of just falling like a regular
booster rocket super heavy will perform
a retropropulsive landing
retropropulsion is when a rocket engine
is used in the opposite direction of the
motion of the rocket to reduce its
velocity and break the rocket so to
speak similar to how falcon 9 does a
suicide burn and then land safely but
according to elon musk he has different
plans instead of the super heavy slowing
down and landing on its legs spacex
plans to catch the super heavy using
large robotic arms connected to the
landing tower they proposed that this
would put less stress on the landing
legs and that would mean less
refurbishment of parts that have to
absorb the kind of force a heavy rocket
would face in a landing like that so a
massive rocket that can be produced at
mass scale at an accelerated speed that
is reusable and produces such a high
thrust what is there not to like about
the super heavy fun fact with the
starship stacked on top of the super
heavy it stands at a height of about 120
meters making the full starship the
longest space rocket in history it beat
out the sls block 2 cargo and saturn 5
by 9 meters the super heavy bm-3
underwent the first cryogenic proof test
successfully on july 13th the test
seemed to be a success but all the fans
are waiting in excitement for the first
flight test that will be performed on
the super heavy bn4 according to the
flight plan that spacex has submitted to
the federal aviation administration the
starship sn20 will launch from the
orbital launch pad at star base in boca
chica texas about three minutes into the
flight super heavy will separate and
descend into the gulf of mexico off the
coast of bokuchika meanwhile the upper
stage starship will continue the ascent
to about 328 thousand feet before
landing 100 kilometers northwest of the
island of kauai in hawaii so all we need
to do is wait and see how the super
heavy bn4 performs in the actual flight
test this will be the first time we will
see the super heavy booster in action we
have already seen the second stage past
the launch and landing test earlier this
year now it's the time of reckoning for
the giant booster rocket but we have to
remember it took spacex multiple launch
attempts of their falcon 9 to finally
nail the launch and landing of their
current flagship rocket so even if bn4
doesn't perform as expected you can be
sure that spacex will continue to make
it better